so part c
find the x coordinates of all points of
inflection for the graph of f give a
reason for your answer so points of
inflection
points of inflection
happen
when
we go
from
concave upwards
concave
upwards
to downwards
to
downwards
or vice versa or
vice versa
so this is true if and only if
f prime prime of x
goes from
goes
from
positive
to
negative
negative or vice versa
or
vice
versa
so where do we see f prime prime of x
going from positive to negative well
that's going to be true that's going to
be true if and only if
f prime of x
goes from
being increasing to decreasing or vice
versa f prime
goes
from
increasing
to decreasing
decreasing or
vice versa i'm using a lot of vice versa
here so now let's and i wanted to think
of it in terms of f prime because we
have the graph of f prime so f prime
goes from increasing to decreasing or
vice versa or we could go from
decreasing to increasing
well let's think about it let's see over
here f prime is
f prime is decreasing decreasing
decreasing decreasing
and then it increases so we have a point
of inflection right over here right when
f prime of x is 0.
so and that's because f prime is
differentiable so the derivative is
definitely it's the derivative is zero
right at that point of inflection right
over here so if that happens at x equals
negative one
and over here f then f prime starts
increasing but then it right at x equals
one then it starts decreasing
so at x equals one we have another point
of inflection and that's where we have
that
zero
that the the zero
a tangent line with slope zero and then
we're decreasing decreasing decreasing
decreasing decreasing increasing all
right so this is going to be another
point of inflection x equals 3. so these
are our three pointers points of
inflection
so this happens
happens
at
x equals negative one
x equals one and x equals three
so these three points
in on on our graph of f prime where we
see f prime goes from decreasing to
increasing or increasing to decreasing
or decreasing to increasing all right
all right
now
well i'll do the last part of the next
video